todos os países do mundo já entrou em
contato com o conflito ou repressão e
principalmente as pessoas que moram nele
tiver esse sentimento mais marcada na
sua vida
eu sei que a minha própria história o
que é se sentir humilhado um fracassado
um cpd toda sua expectativa de vida toda
sua esperança não tinham como as coisas
podem melhorar
eu fui pra recuperação em praticamente
todas as séries do colégio juntamente
com a dar inteira meus estudos foi nada
bem
meu primeiro amigo eu vim te na segunda
vez que eu fiz um primeiro no maranhão
então eu descobri que depois de um tempo
que eu tinha essa época da depressão e
que a pressão não é apenas tristeza o
luto é doença da pressão é quando o que
é realmente a versão da pressão é quando
no cérebro receptores são neuton
emissores que são na linda com nove na
linha em serotonina eles comunicam entre
o cérebro são mensageiros e a depressão
afeta essa comunicação causando
alterações reais no cérebro e depressão
a doença que pode ser diagnosticada que
pode ser medida
quando eu estava nessa época eu
acreditei que por mim mesmo eu não ia
conseguir mudar isso
então o povo é o melhor plano
eu resolvi entrar eu dormi por uma
situação em que eu não pudesse controlar
o que eu fiz
o exército vai fazer o curso de formação
de oficiais da reserva e dentro desse
curso talvez não tenha sido a melhor e
minhas idéias pois a depressão somada a
própria pressão e eu acabei entrando em
depressão profunda e aí em depressão
profunda dentro do exército
eu acabei que as coisas vão piorando te
olhando lá no fundo do poço eu já num
já não conseguia mais vê melhora já eu
vi que a vida já que é dado que tem que
dar então nenhum este campo à noite
depois de brilhar enquanto todos dormiam
eu já
já o esquema domingo eu já não comia
mais
então eu resolvi que era isso que eu
peguei o meu fuzil da gm foi na cabeça
então a própria neurofisiologia a
neurociência ela mostra como ao humano é
um animal extremamente emocional
o como o instinto de sobrevivência ele é
ele atua a partir da unita emoção uma
cognição e depois desse evento no dia
seguinte eu acordei e vi que havia
morrido ali
agora tá na hora de viver não vou
esperar mais a vida e oferecer o que ela
tem de fazer o que quiser
quero realmente em eu quero agora a
entender que quer saber qual funciona o
comportamento alcançado foi que eu tive
depois daquele evento ali eu passei a
querer entender as coisas
o choque foi tão grande eu tive um
evento tão grande que aconteceu um
fenômeno sabe a gente chama dinheiro pa
cidade em que é a remodelação do cérebro
a partir de eventos neuronais que pode
ser de ensinar os gêneros como da
esquerda ou variação de neurônios na
redação deles quando a direita e esses
eventos acontecem geralmente após um
grande evento de aprendizado a vencer o
estresse
então eu resolvi ok isso foi mais ou
menos comigo mas eu não entendendo eu
quero tentar entender um pouco mais da
humanidade eu entender um pouco mais o
comportamento dele sobre conflitos e
cárter estudo que a guerra faz o que a
pressão eo estresse faz com as pessoas
então eu fui eu que o exército e fugir
da relações internacionais
em relações internacionais e eu até
pensei em parar diplomática mas é muito
papel muita burocracia para mim então eu
tive contato com a área que foi a de
negociação com terroristas
e aí eu fiquei entender qual o motivo
eles têm para se tornar terroristas como
eles conseguiam realizar aqueles atos
como é que eles conseguiram matar esse
comportamento montar estratégias
elaboradas por quê como e aí eram
perguntas que naquela aquela área pelas
relações nacionais
eu estudei muito muito mesmo mas eu não
consegui encontrar resposta lenta então
eu resolvi tentar entender a coisa mais
a fundo
eu resolvi que eu precisava entender
desde as moléculas até o comportamento
eu fui eu fui assim e aí eu resolvi
fazer o que agora nenhum caso o cérebro
psicologia muito bem e agora vou te dar
uma coisa mais palpável da adversária
e aí eu vou fazer por isso da
neurofisiologia como biomédico e o que
foi que eu aprendi que o comportamento
ele não é a raiz do problema é só a
expressão dele o que eu estou fazendo
estou falando como tentar junto com
vocês aqui é só o resultado de uma
reação física ou química do cérebro foi
que nessa área frontal está já a sua
cognição a unasul e dentária e
principalmente aqui no pré frontal essa
área mais inferior é onde está a tomar a
decisão e ele toma como referência as
suas memórias sua experiência
ok então agora eu sei onde fica e mais
ou menos como acontece mas o que altera
o comportamento das pessoas o que faz
elas mudarem tanto
então eu
o estresse estresse é um evento que ele
normalmente liberam libera um hormônio
chamado cortisol que ele nível muito
alto muito alto e ele acaba matando
outras células porque queria fazer ele
vai maturar
ele vai dar energia e lima ele é
originalmente uma gama de bom é um meio
de sobrevivência ele vai dá energia para
ir lá e vencer o problema então que só
que quando o swell moura liberado com
muita força e acaba matando neurônios
matando as células o que ele quer
maturar elas tanto tanto esforço está
matando elas
e quando acontece esse evento
essa área do cérebro chamada hipocampo
que acontece onde acontece a fixação da
memória é uma das primeiras a morrer a
setop deteriorado e aí se esse estresse
muito alto mas essa área do cérebro
responsável pelas memórias tem a sua
personalidade
ela é composta pelas suas memórias então
essas alterações de estresse muito altas
altera seu comportamento por alterar o
mecanismo responsável pelo como você se
identifica nesse mundo que são suas
memórias
isso aqui foi um evento com um acidente
com o filho que é um caso que é muito
falada neurociências que foi o seguinte
essa barra de aço dele ou de uma
detonação estava correndo perto e ela
entrou pela bochecha atravessou o crânio
e pegou só o lobo frontal aquela área
porque antes eu falei de itamar a
convenção editarem e aí conseguiu
remover ela sobreviver à cirurgia ele
ficou bem só que as pessoas que
trabalham com ele disseram que após a
cirurgia
militando totalmente fisicamente bem
teve alteração total do comportamento
dele
ele virou outra pessoa ele realmente
mudou totalmente o comportamento dele
para ele não reconhecia mais alguns
amigos como amigos
ele já não já não aceitava situações
sociais que antes eram comuns pra ele
pra ele agora não eram coisas legais e
coisas que ele gostava de não gostar
é é mudou a percepção de mundo deles e
aí se a gente tem todos esses fenômenos
que acontecem que alteram a sua
identidade com o mundo como você
interpreta o mundo como a gente sabe
quantos crimes ocorreram por conta
alterações fisiológicas que é de pressão
mantém as piores memórias vividas
se o estresse mata onde está o império
se você demorar novas citou esses
mecanismos estão agindo nesse item
pessoas que podem ter realizado crimes
quantos crimes podem ser evitados
simplesmente com métodos fisiológicos
com a própria tinha então a gente sabe
que quando essa memória é afetada ou
pelo portal que usa como referência
você pede solução de julgamento não
consegue diferenciar muito bem o certo
do errado
se você está fazendo corresponde que
você queria e isso torna as pessoas
muito une prováveis elas são muito fácil
de convencer então em uma situação em
que a sociedade ela é movida o
comportamento dela levada pela
quantidade de pessoas que têm nela que
são muito influenciadas youtube até
políticos e pessoas que influenciam
muitas outras o que influencia fitou no
comportamento social marketing é assim
que funciona a economia
e então se você tem esse público que
depois alterações fisiológicas já é
bastante influenciável e pessoas
altamente influenciáveis você tem
eventos que são mais altas fotos
só que ainda é mais alto ainda essas
pessoas elas já começam a perder a noção
de tentarem pertencimento disse
e isso acaba gerando um caos social
e essas pessoas acabam por se tornarem
pessoas que vão causar problemas sociais
e aí o que acontece normalmente
no entanto ele vai trazer segurança pão
esse é o argumento comumente e acontecem
pela ditadura é assim essa valsa sistema
e adentrou a casa mas o que mais
estresse com mais estresse as pessoas
pensem o sentimento agora de
sobrevivência
ele não precisa mais e não mais têm
necessidade de continuar vivos
então que começa a surgir os
guerrilheiros terroristas terroristas é
um dos maiores causas que a gente tem um
dos maiores problemas que a gente tem é
tentar entender como eles conseguem
agregar tantas pessoas a causa deles
porque tecnicamente um grupo pequeno e
isolado terroristas é para ser
impossível eles conseguirem fazer o
cálculo de fase em diante só que o grupo
aumenta de um modo em controlá lo e aí
analisando com a neural mais o
conhecimento sociologia mais história e
paralisando existe uma questão e se
todas as pessoas que estão sofrendo
estão sob estresse em que seu mecanismo
de as piores memórias vividas ou então
de seu julgamento
elas se sentem pertencentes àquela causa
aquela causa envolve a dor deles então e
se juntou a ela e assim que os grandes
grupos terroristas acontecem
a exclusão no mundo a exclusão a
rejeição é a maior causa de conflitos na
história da humanidade
se você tem essa e se esse evento
acontece com você e você ser rejeitado
socialmente excluídas do momento então
você acaba por se sentir realmente
prejudicado a nível de vocês que doou o
cérebro não consegue interpretar diferir
muito bem entre o trauma emocional e
trauma físico então a rejeição à
exclusão é literalmente uma do real
então as pessoas que estão sob todas
sentimento do sobre todo esse evento
que tal ter um seu seu mesma pegada de
julgamento e eles vêm com uma saída um
sentimento de pertencimento um ganho de
9 identidade e pertencer àquele 6 sendo
aquela religião ou daquele grupo e eles
vão assistir atuantes
então a gente acaba por saber que uma
sociedade moldada em um sistema de
exclusão está fadada totalmente a
violência ea divisão
todo esse mecanismo que viu fica fácil
saber o conta ótico é uma sociedade em
que o estresse é muito alto e aí
por fim dizer que dar valor não
repudiarmos desde que não vai contra a
sua própria vida pois é muito comum usar
de argumentos parecidos para propor
religião e se propor alterações de
comportamento só que discuta e bolachas
e biscoito é o que mais discute se a
alteração de comportamento aquela pessoa
o céu deve viver ou não socialmente em
quatro coisas que são pertença a uma
noção do sentimento que move em questão
seu instinto de sobrevivência à
liberdade
sim sobrevivência a liberdade e o seu
sentimento de pertencimento e esse
sentimento conhecimento da sociedade às
vezes o chamado canal
talvez com a vida dele ou talvez com
milhões de outras
obrigado
[Aplausos]